learn to delegate better so I'm
currently mentoring three people on my
team in two different businesses to
become better leaders and to teach them
to become entrepreneurs and one of the
hardest parts that they have in their
growth is figuring out what to delegate
and what they should do themselves and
often they try to do too much themselves
and they don't give enough people under
them trust and basically willingness to
teach and develop them where they think
I can do everything myself but then also
they'll give off things that they should
be doing themselves I think just the
recognition and awareness of what you
should be doing something it's so
important for people to learn and it's
one of the biggest things that I'm
recently working with Alex to log on in
the internal dance salsa and getting him
to train the person who's under him who
I hired for him to be an administrative
assistant and and he wants to give off
some tasks like customer service emails
that he sees just as a as an admin's or
it's not an admin job it's really you
know customer service is too important
to be left to the customer service
department where the customer service
should be something that you take really
seriously and should be led by somebody
who really cares and not just giving off
to an administrative person and in this
case also aardman person has she's
English as a Second Language it doesn't
doesn't quite get the culture and speak
the language and so that should be high
priority for Alex to do but then he'll
do a lot of admin stuff that he
shouldn't be doing that is insanely low
value low leverage and by training the
person to help him he could save a lot
of time and so how does relates to my
book is the past week so i'm in orlando
right now that is Airbnb place it's a
beautiful sunny day getting used to the
the heat and humidity is our first full
day here so I haven't got a lot on the
book but what I've done is the next step
in what I have to do besides fight with
the publisher with the sections I
haven't heard back from that by the way
I'm where
stand so I'll keep you guys updated as
we go through but the next step is more
administrative where I've quoted a lot
of people in the book a lot of people
have contributed and as the book has
been edited and cut and you know worked
I need to now give a final copy of those
pieces to the people who've contributed
so everything that I've quoted somebody
as saying I need to make sure that
they're on board with it that they you
know they agree to have that imprint and
getting kind of signed off so there's no
legal issues that's a lot of work it's a
lot of it been work and it's not work
that I should be doing I should be doing
higher leverage stuff and some of a sign
that somebody on my team where take
every mention of somebody every coat
that we've done and mix them in some
cases it may only be one quote and maybe
a couple sentences and in some cases it
might be pages and pages and pages of
content and basically create a separate
word document for each person and give
that to me so i can send that off to the
person to get their feedback and this is
important because the work of compiling
it is not high leverage for me to do i
take somebody you know it takes a human
being to do but it's not something that
i should be doing but then the process
of following up with them is going to be
me to do because the relationship is
important because i want them to say yes
I want them to sign off and the fact
that I view that relationship as a
priority and don't just give it to
somebody under me to deal with them
shows how much I value them and so
that's important right where people
might think well that's just a
administrative thing to get them to sign
off on it just have your system take
care of all it for them and I think that
the communications part is massively
important and should be done by somebody
who you know ideally is you or if not
you somebody who's not just an
administrative person I fight with the
sage guys all the time about having
everything go through the communications
department before it gets Steven or
before you a message gets out and again
like communication is too important to
be left to the communications department
because they will they won't ruin it
they will always ruin it and they kill
the heart out of the mess
and so for the book the process of
collecting the information that is not
public facing it's definitely not
something I should be doing but I will
be the one reaching out and that is a
high leverage use of my time so to your
questions only one question is weak
because all you guys were wishing Nina a
happy birthday and I love it I respect
it I appreciate it Nina's gonna love it
as well thank you guys for doing that
and you know the the vibe believe nation
I really hits me here right it's been
the heart i love you guys so much in the
care that even though you know I haven't
met most of you in person I feel like
there's definitely a bond and I know
Nina does too i know the rest of people
my team does too and it's really a
special thing and i really appreciate
you guys took the time out of your day
to send nina a happy message and i know
what that's going to mean a lot to her
so there's one question that came in
from paul chain wrote in to say how
about having two versions a short
version hard copy published and an extra
downloadable version with the fifty
percent the publisher chopped off it's
like me doing full time for cash flow
and part-time my passion i could spend
45 hours a week right in eBook now we
can have both thanks so this an
interesting idea I think that the
challenge with a with doing a book is
you know the rights get a sign over to
the publisher I own some rights I get on
the YouTube rights I own some other
options on it but the rights get signed
up to publisher and so I need to be just
a little bit careful what I deal with it
and the stuff that I cut that the
publisher doesn't want I also want to
make sure you know I own that why am i
why should I give that up if it's not
gonna make it into the full ver
full-blown version so i have to see what
I want to do with it you know that the
half that is stain is has been looked at
a lot of times as been polished has been
refined the half that isn't stain has
not been edited as much it's a lot more
raw there's probably typos in there I'm
sure parts could be cut down even more I
don't know I'm thinking of releasing it
as bonus content whether it's for people
who buy short number of books or within
a certain timeframe or
or what I don't know I haven't figured
it again I'm not in the market mindset
yet getting close to it right now I want
to get the book out what I'm doing
basically right now is waiting for the
publisher to get back to me about the
three issues that I'm fighting over and
then sending off the copies to the
people that need to kind of sign off on
a 24 their parts in the book that's
pretty much it for now I wanna I'm
itching to get going on the marketing
I'm here I'm relaxing this week you know
Orlando our annual trip family trip to
Disneyland I'm sorry Disney World but
when I get back I i I'm I hate it when
projects drag on and I know you guys to
do to like I hate having to wait two
weeks to get an answer from the
publisher and the secret there is just
hustle while you wait like you're
waiting on something don't just wait
start hustling in another direction so
you might be waiting at a bunch of
people plant new seeds keep on hustling
because the wait will kill you and
that's the secret to a lot of success
for Entrepreneurship not the topic of
this video but I said wait there and I
like it hustle why you wait cool well
thank you guys for joining for another
video I'd love to hear your thoughts and
if you have a question about delegation
the topic at the top if you have a
question with Hudson while you were if
you have a question about my book or the
book writing process leave in the
comments below and I will answer in next
week's video thank you guys so much for
watching really feel the love from both
me and Nina thank you so much continue
to believe this way and i'll see you
soon